[Musique]
sofia est avec nous merci d'être là je
sais vous venez de me dire c'est très
difficile vous avez eu alors on va pas
dire on se trouve la crèche que je crois
que vous avez eu d'énormes pressions
pour ne pas venir témoigner ce soit oui
c'était 23 décembre
vous êtes au travail votre enfant est à
la crèche et vous recevez un appel on
vous dit quoi on m'appelle pour me dire
de venir récupérer mon fils se demande
pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe et on
m'explique que monfils s'est fait mal la
voix tremblante de la directrice
adjointe et là je dis même si ces faits
main
vous pourrez parler bien force convivial
avec le masque s'est désolé donc du coup
je demande c'est si grave que ça pour
venir le récupérer après une morsure
memphis était déjà fait vendre une ou
deux fois j'avais déjà prévenu on va
dire quelque chose
des choses qui peuvent arriver et là au
vu de sa voix j'ai compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas donc
d'accord travail exactement il a quinze
mois je travaille j'ai appelé mon mari
pour lui demander d'aller récupérer mon
fils
voilà je ne sachant pas encore ce qui
s'était passé alors vous décidez donc de
venir le récupérer à la crèche oui et là
c'est incroyable ce que vous ce que vous
voyez
ouais bah ouais en fait mon mari me vois
une photo voilà de mon fils comme ça
c'est resté sans voix enfin on ne savait
pas quoi faire quoi dire
il a demandé ce qui s'était passé ouais
il a demandé ce qui s'était pas leurs
yeux on nous a expliqué que qui s'était
fait mordre
pendant sa sieste voilà mes jav en mari
resté vraiment sans voix savais pas quoi
dire savais pas quoi faire donc comme
moi je lui ai demandé de l'emmener aux
urgences on pouvait pas laisser comme ça
sachant que la crèche n'a rien fait bien
sûr n'a pas la langue
vous intervenez en plus et c'est ça qui
est très grave vous apprenez que on vous
appelle mais les faits ils viennent pas
d'arriver ils sont arrivés il y a trois
heures donc on a laissé le petit pendant
trois heures à la crèche comme ça dont
les gens sont occupés et si ça paraît
souffrir devant mdi parce que il va
énormément nous vous à vous appeler
trois heures après comment ça se fait je
ne les explique pas je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas me l'expliquer en fait sur le
coup on n'a pas su on nous a pas dit que
ça s'était passé il ya 3 heures la foule
comme ça et en fait j'ai tout simplement
demandé à mon mari m'a dit donne moi le
déroulé de la journée et qu'elle
comptait ce qu'il a mangé est ce qu'elle
a été quels ont été les siestes les
horaires et c est en fait mon mari m'a
dit j'ai même pas pu demander tellement
j'étais perturbé et tellement ça m'a
traumatisée donc du coup ce que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai appelé la crèche et
j'ai demandé en fait les transmissions
de la journée donc le déroulé de la
journée alors et les explications qui
ont été donnés à mon mari sait que c'est
que c'est que n'at elle s'était fait
mordre pendant le temps de sieste et là
on me dit que mon fils dans les
transmissions a dormi de 12h30 à 13h30
pourquoi est donc là je dis mais
ça s'est passé durant sa sieste donc ça
s'est passé à 13h30 et là on me répond
oui et il a clairement babolat il ya un
blanc je sais pas quoi faire je ne sais
pas quoi répéter je suis leur dit mais
vous me prévenez trois heures après vous
me prévenez 3 a rappelé m après vous
n'appelez personnes vous ne prévenez
personnes on né le 23 décembre
la crèche ferme à 19 heures il est 16h30
c'est incroyable alors voilà vous
décidez de faire une expertise médicale
et qu'est ce que vous dit le médecin
ouais ouais ouais je veux dire mon mari
de pas laisser mon fils comme ça de
l'emmener aux urgences et le médecin il
nous dit que c'est tout frais déjà ils
nous ont dit que que ça peut être une
morsure mais qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses autour voilà il ya des hématomes
il ya il ya sous l'oreille elle a
quadruplé de volume enfin vous voyez
c'est pas je peux même pas regarder
c'est ce qu'on s'en serve à jean
toussaint voilà il avait porté plainte
oui ça partait plein contre contre la
crèche oui bien sûr oui bien sûr contre
la crèche qu'est ce qu'on vous a répondu
où ça à la crise qui vous ont répondu
les gens de la trêve ont répondu puis
s'était fait mordre durant son sommeil
mais voilà c'est que par un autre enfant
bah je me suis demandée ce n'était pas
un animal et il y avait personne qu'ils
surveillaient et ben apparemment
non personne personnes étaient là au
moment où aussi ces faits montre mon
fils n'a pas pu enfin il ya clairement
du mensonge mon fils même si il a pu se
faire mordre n'y a pas que ça mais oui
mon fils a dû pleurer des minutes mais
tellement longue monfils a dû souffrir
fin ce que je leur disais c'est que ce
qu'elle me disait était inaudible
je sais que vous souhaitiez exprimer
votre colère au ministre de la
protection de l'enfance
adrien taquet pour que ça bouge où il
avait essayé de le joindre
non j'ai pas et c'est déjà chez que lui
il a essayé de lima il a écrit et il me
dit vous recevez sofia ce soir dans le
petit garçon a été mordu au sein de sa
crèche alors lui apparemment il a eu
donc la version voilà que nous avait
donné qu' apparemment dit qu'il a été
mordue j'espère avant toute chose qu
elle va bien car c'est ça le plus
important c'est que nous avons pris
contact avec les autorités responsables
afin de nous assurer que toutes les
procédures avaient bien été lancée pour
comprendre ce qui s'était passé et
éviter que cela puisse se reproduire à
l'avenir la crèche doit transmettre son
rapport d'incident à la mairie et une
visite de la pmi protection maternelle
et infantile est programmée je crois que
sofia et son mari ont eu des contacts
avec la mairie pourra par ailleurs pour
essayer de trouver une solution pour
l'enfant voilà donc il est apparemment
sur le dossier j'espère que ça va
avancer brou j'espère qu'on va trouver
surtout une nouvelle crèche sont à votre
enfant j'espère que vous pourrez savoir
ce qui s'est passé
j'espère qui va aller mieux et vraiment
tenez nous au courant